you
[Music]
sure my friend you know how many reasons
we have to be desperate and despairing
the world is not learning anything we
have seen that you and I went through
certain experiences if anyone had told
us in 1945 that there are certain
battles we'll have to fight again they
would have believed it racism
anti-semitism starvation of children and
would have believed that because I was
convinced then I Eve Lee that at least
something happened in history that
because of let's say Auschwitz certain
things will not happen again I was
convinced that hatred among nations and
among people perished in Auschwitz
he didn't the victims died but the
haters are still here new ones and so
often I say to myself really what are we
doing and this planet we are we are
passing the message as well as we can
communicating our fears our hopes and
they in day out week after week and year
after year people kill each other
you
[Music]